what does she mean by that really that's
not her business you know we just I'm
just like what we like well things got
real personal on the latest episode of
the hills and Brody and kaylynn's
marriage or open marriage was the center
of a halva gossip people were talking
about me and Brody and our personal life
saying that we have an open relationship
Kaitlyn was a little upset with all the
chatter when Brody and I first worked
together we were young we were crazy we
were like you know basically just trying
to have the time of our lives so we did
a lot of things in our relationship that
you know I certainly wouldn't say I
regret but the level of gossip that I
feel happens in the group it just makes
me angry we just need you to say what we
were really feeling and thinking because
I way you don't get into trouble it's
like that you really feel it turns out
though Brody's the one who opened the
can of worms on a national podcast
seriously Brody's actually the one that
said they had an open relationship on a
national podcast
like Brody should never have been doing
that
does she really think people aren't
gonna gossip about that I'm perfect of
course since that was all filmed Brody
and Kaitlynn have splits
Caitlin and Miley Cyrus have been
inseparable and rody is spending time
with model Josie Canseco come here come
here
hey yeah Brody and Kaitlyn's
relationship has been a roller coaster
to watch on the hills what's it like
sleeping in a car in your daughter's day
I didn't just randomly come home and
decide to sleep in a car I came home to
a psychopath yelling and screaming at me
because I came home at a certain time
from that to well talking about wanting
to start a family what Whitney and Tim
have is pretty much exactly what I would
like for Brody and I to have eventually
as a family something they also talk to
et about are you talking about expanding
the family yeah I mean we don't have a
specific timeline but we're definitely
getting to the night right after this
event the timeline yes we are gonna
start trying right over a bad time to
try never know yeah if it happens it
happens man what a journey what do you
guys think of all of this let me know
and for all the latest on Brody
Kaitlyn my leave and this story keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krause and bye for now